yeah so I'm old enough to remember the
alarms on walking on the moon and I was
six years old when I when I when he when
he did that and I and that really caught
my attention and I wanted that's when
it's set the seeds in my head that I
wanted to grow up to be an astronaut you
know just seeing that on the TV screen
was really caught my attention but you
know when I went to high school
elementary school in high school in the
70s I you know I was I may be a typical
high school student I had no idea you
knew I liked math and science so I
wanted to study anybody looked at the
courses you had to take when you got to
college for different majors I wanted to
be an engineer so I was lucky enough to
get into Columbia and I think it was
just so you know I school just was
having fun and trying to do well in
school and trying to get through a good
college and when I got here to Columbia
I was just trying to get successfully
through the school and didn't really
think too much about what I was going to
do afterwards until I got to be a senior
and then when I was a senior a movie
called the right stuff came out that
movie kind of rekindled my my interest
it had me thinking and what got me was
the views out of John Glenn's spaceship
and and also the camaraderie between
those astronauts and you know what they
were doing doing something that I
thought was really important and really
cool it looked like a lot of fun and I
had no idea how I could be coming I was
here I was in New York I didn't like
Heights or you know I didn't I still
don't like Heights quite frankly but
yeah I'd never been on an airplane or
may have been on a plane once at that
point when I was a senior but you know I
hadn't I wasn't a military person I
wasn't very outdoorsy or a thrill seeker
I grew up in New York you know the the
subway was the most exciting thing i did
so i wasn't sure how you know what the
what the deal was but I started looking
into it I applied to grad schools and
look for jobs when I got out of when I
was a senior I took a job and i deferred
grad school and that was good for me
because it gave me a time to think about
what i really
to do and I just could not get this idea
of a space program out of my head and I
didn't know if you know the Astron I
think I found out was like really
competitive and you're impossible but I
thought I could do something for NASA so
I went to grad school with the intent of
pursuing the career with the space
program in an application into the
astronaut office and and that's what I
did and so when I was in grad school
away for a few years I started applying
it took me four tries but finally I was
a was accepted to nat's on my own my
fourth try and that was 17 years ago and
it's been a fun ride ever since so now
what I'm what I'm doing is I'm on loan
from from NASA here at Columbia until
until May for the academic year and my
goal what I'm trying to do is try to
instill a little bit of the space
program and Space engineering into the
curriculum and into the consciousness
here at Columbia and in and in New York
City so the course I'm going to be
teaching is introduction to human
spaceflight and what I want to do is
bring the the the stuff that i found
interesting and the things that I've
learned in the 17 years I've had with
NASA as an astronaut and bring that to
the classroom so I want to concentrate
on people in space what you have to do
to prepare what you look how astronauts
selected how are they trained and what
it's like to be in space the experience
and what you put some of the things you
need to worry about to keep a crew
healthy so how do you get power to the
spaceship how do you keep the crew alive
with life support and how you make
decisions you make decisions on your
power is going to affect how you're
going to produce water for example one
of the other things I want to include in
like in my course is it's not just NASA
doing things now it's also the private
commercial companies trying to put
people into space NASA is working with
some of them directly to help put
astronauts on the space station and low
Earth orbit but there's also some
private companies like Virgin Galactic
who would flying tourists SpaceX for
example is one of the companies and NASA
is working with and that SpaceX sierra
nevada and boeing there are three
companies and that's
with to provide service of getting
people to the space station and what
I've noticed in the students that I've
met that are interested in the space
program they're not just interested in
working for NASA they're interested in
also may be working for one of these
companies so I think the future is
pretty bright I think it's not just NASA
anymore that you can find or NASA
related projects to work on when you
when you graduate but I think it's
opening up the space the opportunity
being space and to work in the space
program through a lot more people and I
really hope that that commercial space
flight takes off because I think that's
where our future is I think NASA needs
to concentrate on going beyond low-earth
orbit getting back to the moon or going
beyond our little neighborhood here so
we're looking for research opportunities
ways in which Columbia faculty can
collaborate with NASA maybe do some
experiments on the space station see
what research they're doing here that
applies to what NASA is doing so try to
set up some research partnerships my
most recent mission four years ago they
made an IMAX movie hubble 3d and it was
also a Warner Brothers movie just like
this gravity movie is and the director
has said that he studied the IMAX movie
as far as the Hubble Space Telescope the
way it looks every piece of it label
screw bolt is all in place and the
payload Bay of the space shuttle which
were used for that mission is exactly
the same they have all the different
equipment carriers we brought equipment
up it took stuff back so you like these
big boxes of things in different very
unique positions and shapes and they're
there so its exact it's an exact replica
of what we had in in space for real and
if they actually did you know just
scenes of our space walks and what we
really do in space no one can watch that
even I have trouble watching it when my
friends are doing it you know as so it's
not a very exciting thing to watch and
they want people to watch a movie so to
have to make it interesting and so they
took some liberties with the store of
how the you know how you would solve
these problems but I it's a movie I
remember when I was a psycho my first
spaceflight I was going to be a space
Walker but I was assigned with the other
three space walkers on that flight
really experienced space walkers and
astronauts they had been on multiple
flights and I was on my first first
flight and I was my first opportunity to
spacewalk as well and i remember a very
first little meeting adequate artist the
four of us the most senior guy it was
kind of like our leader John Grunsfeld
said we're going to make sure that we
are really careful what we're doing
we're going to be good to our equipment
we're going to make sure that when we
put because we you know the other guys
dress the other guys and get them ready
to go to space walk we put each other in
our suits are going to be really careful
about that we're going to double and
triple check everything we don't have
any leaks we're going to be very
methodical and when we're outside we're
going to take care of each other both
inside and outside because everybody's
coming home and that's what that was
kind of set the tone for me that you
know this can be very dangerous this is
a lot of fun it's a great opportunity
but it's also pretty dangerous so you
try to prepare for whatever you can to
meet those hazards that you might might
encounter the actually i think is kind
of interest because it's obvious not the
smartest guy in class that gets picked a
lot of it is more of you know teamwork
ability to get along with people there
are things that aren't necessarily
obvious there's a lot of people at MIT
that applied that we're much more than I
was but I think they're looking for
someone you want to hang out when in
space as a that is so you know the
person is going to have the highest IQ